The answer is on the order
of t squared steps.
The reason for
this comes from two observations.
The first, is that simulating
a step of the multitape machine
with a single tape machine,
involves a number of steps proportional
to the total number of symbols used.
Recall that each step of
the multitape machine
was simulated with two
passes over the tape.
With k tapes, up to k minus one
more passes are possible, for
shifting cells to the right, but
we're treating k as a constant here.
The second observation, is that at step
i of the multitape machine, the number
of symbols used is at most the original
size of the input, plus k times i.
Since at most k symbols can be added
during each step of
the multitape machine M.
Summing over the different
steps of the multitape machine,
we can put a t squared bound
on the first term here.
And then the second term just
becomes the arithmetic sequence,
which we can write like this.
And that also is order t squared.
So that's the answer.